as some ccsd students head back to
in-person class in the morning
they may have some first day of school
jitters bianca holman spoke with doctors
about what parents can do
to ease these fears from computer
screens to the classroom
clark county school district students
have been learning from home since march
of 2020.
as kids prepare to see their teachers in
person they might be a little anxious
professor catherine lee says to have a
calming routine the night before
laying out their clothes and packing
their bag positively encouraged
them just to try it out right because
really what we're trying to encourage in
our children
in general whether it's a pandemic or
not is to feel safe exploring the world
and to know that there are other adults
around them that they
can trust and respect and be safe around
when morning comes parents are the first
step in the district's new safety
protocol
parents are going to be asked to do a
health assessment for their children
30 minutes before they load onto the bus
or 30 minutes before they attend school
that just means make sure your child
isn't sick make sure your child doesn't
have cough
runny nose sore throat vomiting diarrhea
or fever greater than 100.4 degrees
because if any of those symptoms are
present your child should stay home
if you aren't able to put the
thermometer under your child's tongue
then you can place it in their armpit
for a proper reading
kids will wear masks most of the time at
school only taking it off to eat or
drink
doctors say the child should have a
properly fitting mask they can adjust on
their own
other helpful items students should have
in their book bag include hand sanitizer
and wipes bianca holman 8 news now